américa latina se blinda en la víspera
de las fiestas ante el aumento de los
contagios y con la sombra de la nueva
cepa en reinounido varios países han
restringido los accesos y han endurecido
medidas con la mira puesta en navidad y
año nuevo en colombia medellín impuso un
toque de queda nocturno para el 24 y el
31 de diciembre bogota a la capital
reinstauró las restricciones de acceso a
los comercios según la cédula de
identidad hasta el 15 de enero argentina
por su parte extendió las medidas para
frenar el virus hasta el 31 de enero es
importante tener en cuenta que seguimos
en la gran los ideales localidades y las
publicaciones con transmisión
comunitaria del virus ésta significa de
virus sigue circulando a pesar de que
muchos nace de disminuyendo en uruguay
rigen cierre de fronteras hasta el 10 de
enero se prohíbe la aglomeración de
personas por dos meses y se suspenden
las ceremonias religiosas presenciales
en este panorama chile amplió su toque
de queda nocturno y mantiene la
cuarentena en santiago y ecuador
instauró un nuevo estado de excepción
por 30 días así como un bloqueo nocturno
y la y seca de este sumario distinto
hemos vivido días que nunca imaginamos
y en nuestra peor pesadilla y tenemos
sin duda importantes reacciones que
aprender y lo digo muy en serio no
podemos fallar ahora ahora al menos que
hemos avanzado tanto paradójicamente en
brasil el país latinoamericano más
afectado las playas de río de janeiro
lucieron repletas el fin de semana una
relajación que también alimenta al
presidente ya ir evolucionar o solo en
sao paulo el gobierno estatal llamó a
quedarse en casa mientras se espera
iniciar la vacunación el día de navidad
tras un acuerdo con el laboratorio chino
sinovac para recibir 10 a 8 millones de
dosis de su inmunización de aquí a fin
de año